Christopher Riley, Screenwriter, Author, and
Instructor: I had to be more than 50 years old
to experience that moment of healing.
This to me is the advantage that
writers have with every passing year.
Film Courage: How does a writer find
defining moments in their own life?
Christopher: Kathy and I have developed a
list of characteristics that we think describe
defining moments and that they help us when
we go looking for defining moments. That list
includes things like the moment a dream was
born, it could be the moment a dream died.
Sometimes defining moments
or moments of birth or death
and that can be a literal death or it could be
a figurative death. The death of a business,
the death of a relationship or the
birth of a relationship. We think about
moments of discovery, so for a child who's been
adopted the moment they discover that they were
adopted might redefine their understanding
of themselves. A special kind of discovery
is a lesson that's learned. Dorothy in Oz makes
the discovery that there's no place like home
and that discovery becomes the mantra
that allows her to travel back to Kansas.
It was the discovery that she needed when she
set out from Kansas. She didn't think that the
people at home were special enough to cherish she
thought that real life lay somewhere out there
and along the way she makes the discovery that
there's no place like home and that redefines
who she is sometimes we're looking for a moment
when a wound was suffered or a loss was incurred
other times we're looking for a moment of the
birth of hope or a moment of healing a moment of
deep emotional or spiritual change and with that
it's not a checklist but that those categories
we can look at our own lives and say well
what was a moment of deep emotional change
that I've experienced if I'm a morose person was
I always that way and if not when did that change
Kathy found a an old black and white
picture of her dad when he was a young boy
and Kathy's dad as I knew him
was a serious mechanical engineer
and not not playful that's the last word
I would use for him and yet this picture
showed this impish kid with this
like wicked smile on his face
and Kathy and her brother turned to each
other when they found this picture and said
did you know that person and they both said no
I never met that guy well what was the moment
when he went from the playful imp to the very
serious very dour person that my wife grew up with
that at least turns our gaze in the right
direction and we can start looking and see seeing
is there is there a moment like that now there
are times I think that we can't find the moment
either because it happened when we were
so young that we have no memory of it or
it may be so traumatic that we have
not allowed ourselves to remember it
but we know we walk with the
limp and I discovered in myself
a sort of evidence of a wound that I don't ever
remember suffering but I remember as far back as
six years old having having the damage and so I
don't know what that defining moment was I just
know that it exists and I know that I learned
from that experience that I must not let people
know the real me or they would not want me I
learned that men are dangerous and I had to
I have no memory that accounts for those things
but I had to look at that history nonetheless
and recognize those lies as being so deep in
my in my firmware that I couldn't remember a
time where they weren't there and then I had to
learn the truth that would neutralize those lies
and I still feel like those lies are true but I
now know they're not and I'm able to tell myself
here's the truth there are people who actually
know you and they actually love you and so the
lie that if people know you they won't love you
that's a lie no matter how how that feels and I've
learned I'm not a little little boy anymore and
I don't have to be afraid of grown-ups it's not
actually dangerous to have human encounters
even though it still feels dangerous to me
well so I've just described a moment of
healing that's also a defining moment
I had to be more than 50 years old to experience
that moment of healing this to me is the advantage
that writers have with every passing year we keep
getting more and more life experience and so we
have more and more to draw on if you're 20 well
you've been through middle school so you have
you know you've come through at least one war
that's painful yes and so you know I always
think of the popular kids I'm not sure they
exist I haven't met anyone as an adult who
says oh yeah I breezed through eighth grade it
was awesome my favorite year it's just awful
but a 20 year old is going to have 20 years of
life experience a 40 or a 50 or a 60 year old
writer is going to have more life experience and
so while the industry may have a preference you
know for 22 year old writers because it's exciting
like it's exciting to get a new sports car
mostly we give awards out to people with a little
more mileage on them and it's because in part
of the greater life experience which gives
you more access to these kinds of moments
you know you just jogged my memory because
I knew someone who was considered very
popular and they worried their worry was they
thought hey everyone thought they were stuck up
and b they were worried about their image and
when they left the house how did they look to
everybody so to them that was a huge concern
because they were afraid of breaking that image
and to me I saw the person as had it all together
and they had all these people around them that
wanted to be around them but they were terribly
concerned so I guess you're right that to them
it was still tragic I do think about people whose
faces are on magazine covers and there is a burden
that goes with that now we might think oh you know
boo hoo you're you're beautiful and famous but
there is a there's a burden that goes even with
the popularity that that rises to the level of
celebrity of an acquaintance once said to one of
my children you don't know how hard it is to be so
pretty and at the time I thought that's a line I
need to put in a script but you know as you as you
talk I think no that actually for for
this young lady she experienced that
as as pain and anxiety and all of all of that
kind of human experience is interesting to me
both as a human but also as a storyteller
that's an interesting character
it's not that wasn't my life experience but
it's it's an experience that's interesting to me
is there a limit on how many defining moments
someone can have in their life you know I've
been thinking a lot lately about defining moments
and I keep discovering more of them for myself
I’m not sure that the half dozen is
any sort of absolute limit at all I
you know I think that our lives don't continue
in a straight line there are reversals
there are moments of transformation our
lives seem to unfold kind of in chapters
we don't just do the same thing the
same way forever well the whole world
with covid has experienced that that things
actually change sometimes quite dramatically so
I could probably put my finger on a dozen
moments that from my own life that are
pretty profound and create distinct moments
of before and after so I don't know that
there's an absolute limit I just think that
practically speaking when we come to characters
we probably want to work with a manageable
number of them so that we don't dilute
their impact and their power
especially if we're thinking of a stand-alone
feature film if we're talking about a television
series that goes for many many episodes then you
probably could do justice to a dozen defining
moments over you know 100 episodes if anybody
is doing 100 episodes anymore at some point it
you know Aristotle talked about
how many acts there should be in
any any play and he said well it just
depends how long the play is because an act
has to do with a reversal and there he says
there should be a big reversal in each act
a life that is nothing but reversal starts to
feel not like a real life it would be like a
football game where there was an interception or
a fumble on every play it just becomes absurd but
he says you've got to have enough of them to
keep it interesting so that's his formula he
doesn't tell us you know how many acts there
should be in a one-hour television pilot
but the general principle is there should
be enough to keep it interesting but not
so many that it becomes absurd and I suppose
the same could be said of defining moments.